dans l'actualité syndicale françois
chérèque candidat à la succession de
nicole notât à la tête de la cfdt était
à metz aujourd'hui alors son nom vous
dit peut-être quelque chose françois
chérèque et le fils de jacques chérèque
conseiller régional de lorraine qui fut
lui-même secrétaire général adjoint du
syndicat dans les années 80 pour trait
du fils avec arnaud selvigny et bruno
gollnisch
même si la barbe a remplacé les célèbres
moustaches
il y a un air de famille qui ne trompent
pas françois chérèque est indéniablement
le fils de jacques
militant de la première heure comme son
père 23 ans à la cfdt une forme en
quelque sorte d'hérédité syndicale
la parole était très libre dans la
famille on parlait beaucoup de choses
c'est les choses de la vie
le syndicalisme c'est la vie et est ce
qui se passe pas au quotidien mais on
avait aussi un sujet aussi très
intéressant c'est suisse et le suivi du
rugby parce que nous sommes une famille
de rugbyman et c'était le deuxième sujet
favori de la famille
ceux qui le connaissent le dit
sympathique charismatique aussi de
qualité qui ont certainement aidé cet
éducateur spécialisé à prendre la tête
de la fédération santé sociale la plus
importante de la cfdt
si on devait définir l'homme
non de négociations
qui très proches très proches des
adhérents des militants qui a une force
une capacité de
combat autrui on doit à tout moment dans
le débat en mai prochain
françois chérèque sera candidat au poste
de secrétaire général de la cfdt il
devrait logiquement succéder à nicole
notât
quand on est à la tête d'une grosse
fédération comme la mienne et qu'on nous
propose d'être candidat au poste de
secrétaire général de la cfdt
c'est quelque chose d'assez quittant
dans dans la proposition et c'est
effectivement une démarche qui
semblerait naturel dans l'organisation
après le congrès de nantes
le lorrain devrait donc prendre les
rênes d'un des plus puissants syndicats
de france une force de 830 mille
adhérents avec de l'emploi aux retraites
quelques dossiers chauds en perspective
[Musique]